Critics and viewers agree — Paul Dano's
masked Riddler in "The Batman" is terrifying.
So why are fans cracking up over one of his
scenes?
Keep watching to find out.
Heads up — spoilers ahead!
Matt Reeves' "The Batman" offers up one of
the most realistic and frightening takes on
a DC Comics villain to date, with the Riddler
giving off vibes that are deeply reminiscent
of the Zodiac Killer.
"You know it's like, okay that's like a much
more sort of real…"
"Right.
That's not question marks on a green suit."
"Yes."
But not everything about the "brilliant and
terrifying" character — as The Hollywood
Reporter describes him — is scary on the
surface.
In fact, there's one unintentionally funny
scene involving the Riddler that comes toward
the end of "The Batman" that has many fans
laughing the more they think about it.
The surprisingly comical Riddler scene is
found in the third and final act of the Warner
Brothers flick.
Dano's Riddler is seen attempting to rally
online supporters in an effort to bring chaos
and violence to Gotham.
But what he really comes off as is just some
"dorky streamer guy," as fans put it on Reddit.
"I just ordered a slice of pumpkin pie."
In a moment where fiction comes hilariously
close to reality, a team of Gotham City police
officers and Batman discover a dark web social
media profile where they learn Riddler's been
posting regular updates to his 500-plus followers.
It would appear that the main antagonist of
"The Batman" is interacting online with supporters
as if he's an Instagram or YouTube influencer.
He addresses them by saying,
"Hey guys, welcome back to my channel."
The video has racked up tons of heart emojis,
or "likes" from followers who also contribute
comments to show their allegiance.
The video shows Riddler going so far as to
thank his growing brood for, quote, "liking,
commenting, and subscribing" to his channel
— while also showing his appreciation for
some advice that people gave him regarding
bomb detonators.
“There’s a bomb around his neck!”
"The Batman" fans took to a Reddit post to
discuss this particular scene, pointing out
how the third-act reveal risks neutralizing
any threatening energy Riddler gives off earlier
in the movie.
One Redditor wrote,
"I love how he does the creepy Zodiac thing
for the police and the media, but then that
last video for his followers was one of those
dorky 'Hey guys, thanks for the comments,
like and subscribe' videos like every random
YouTuber."
Another Reddit user replied,
"That dichotomy was so f—ing funny without
it feeling telegraphed or forced."
Both of the Redditors' comments received more
than 2,000 upvotes combined.
What ultimately makes the scene hilarious
for moviegoers is the juxtaposition of Dano's
wild and chaotic masked Riddler with his quiet
side which conjures up comparisons to the
incel community, as the Redditors put it.
Still, while a lot of filmgoers were laughing
at the scene, many were also deeply disturbed
by it and other clips that the Riddler released
throughout the movie.
One Reddit user admitted,
"It felt so unnerving and chilling to watch
how Riddler can be this devious yet calculated
serial killer one moment to this dorky streamer
guy."
Another person agreed, saying,
"Legit, Paul had the serial killer/incel/school
shooter persona down so well it was both uncanny
and supremely entertaining."
A third user chimed in, adding,
"It was even the same with his face to face
with Batman.
You see him just do an about-face from calculated
sociopath to crazy manic on a dime multiple
times.
It was a little bit unsettling."
According to Collider, Matt Reeves' Riddler
was ultimately inspired by the director's
fascination with the Zodiac Killer, which
grew after reading the 1995 non-fiction book,
"Mindhunter: Inside the FBI's Elite Serial
Crime Unit."
The book later inspired a Netflix show of
the same name.
What a lot of moviegoers might not know is
that Reeves also intended for his Riddler
to be a mass killer-terrorist of sorts, as
seen when he attacks a Gotham City funeral
using a car and unwilling victim as the driver.
Reeves told Total Film,
"He's not just a serial killer.
He definitely has a political agenda.
There's a terrorist aspect to him."
"The riddles were both, uh, fun but also emotional
and they are layered themselves."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.